so quarantine fatigue is it's a real
thing and when I talk about quarantine
fatigue I'm not talking about the
furious gun-toting protesters that are
demanding states be haphazardly open
back up even when it's clear that states
can't be opened back up when I talk
about quarantine fatigue like an adult
I'm talking to the other adults who have
been doing what the public health
officials are telling us we have to do
and who may be experiencing different
types of quarantine fatigue this can be
psychological this can be physical for
people who are just around less and
moving around less and it can of course
be economic which we've been talking
about as well the people in the
coronavirus is a hoax this is government
tyranny camp they're living in another
world that's not who I'm trying to
engage with here but I do think that
it's completely reasonable that by this
point if you're in one of the states
that is eight weeks in to stay at home
orders even even longer or close to it
in any case there is significant fatigue
that comes with self isolation and the
guidelines that we've been following and
I want to talk about a few different
things one is of course what we're doing
is to flatten the curve and we
understand that nobody's questioning
that piece and that's why we're doing it
when we go out we have to wear masks and
doors and in places where you can't stay
six feet away from people you're not
supposed to see friends and family that
you don't live with in many professions
you're either working from home if
you're lucky or you could be laid off or
or even permanently fired your business
may have closed for good
but people can only do it at a hundred
percent for so long and the question is
becoming as people become more fatigued
what should be done
clearly flipping a switch and going back
to the way things were would be a
disaster and we would undo a lot of the
progress that we've actually made in the
last four six eight or even nine weeks
that this has been going on but
maintaining things exactly as they have
been in the most closed States is
starting to approach an expiration date
so what should be done there's a really
good piece in the Atlantic which
explains if you just insist on keeping
everything as is keeping the strictest
quarantine it's sort of like abstinence
only sex education which we all know
doesn't work it's not realistic it does
not actually work the more reasonable
thing would be to be clear with people
and have better more detailed guidelines
about what people can do so let me talk
about the all along stuff and then the
moving forward all along it would have
been better to get federal guidance on
things that you should do for example go
outside 15 minutes every day a lot of
people are not lis not even stepping out
of the door even if it's your front step
or your building's roof or a backyard
you know depending whether you're urban
rural whatever just about everybody can
step outside for 15 minutes and every
week we're learning more about the
connection between vitamin D and
coronavirus we don't know that it's
causal we see a correlation right now
but it certainly won't help I'm sorry it
certainly won't hurt if everybody gets
15 minutes of Sun every day total
vitamin D would be up fewer people would
be deficient mood improves with sunlight
and outdoors and risk is very low if you
can't step outside without being six
feet away from people then you gotta
wear a mask great would have been great
to have clarity on that earlier most of
the transmission is happening in doors
between people living together then you
have transmission at indoor workplaces
and health facilities then you have
transmission at indoor essential
businesses right like grocery stores etc
very far down is transmission from
people outdoors
of course if people are responsibly
crowd together on a narrow hiking trail
it's bad but the transmission happening
outside from people passing each other
on bikes this type of stuff that that's
been spreading as if it's extremely
dangerous it's not zero but it is
extraordinarily low and think of the
good of people getting outside getting
sunshine and hopefully doing some
exercise walking around etc federal and
state guidance on what are considered
low risk versus high risk activities
would be great for example and New York
is now doing this tennis versus
basketball I think I don't have to
explain why there's a dramatic
difference there also
reduction tactics for people who are
determined that they are just gonna do
high-risk activities we are seeing that
a lot of people just don't listen to the
guidelines in any other public health
venue we would provide harm reduction if
you are going to inject heroin we at
least want to make sure you have a clean
needle so you're not spreading HIV if
you are going to be sexually active we
prefer you do it safely and give people
access to contraceptives and sex
education if you are going to absolutely
be doing an activity like this or that
here are the things you absolutely must
do to reduce the risk now moving forward
there are governors that are managing
the psychological component of this
better than others I'll give you an
example is New York ready to open of
course not
the numbers are dramatically improved
but the answer is they're not ready yet
so what is Andrew Cuomo doing the
governor there he announced three
advancements so to speak yesterday
number one so this is all starting
Friday landscaping and gardening
businesses will be allowed to open these
are businesses where workers don't even
have to interact with customers it's
outdoors this makes sense and it is
businesses that get to open some people
that get to go to work
that's a good thing outdoor low-risk
recreational activities like tennis
again being able to play tennis outdoors
but not basketball it makes sense
everyone's really close together in
basketball not so in tennis and Andrew
Cuomo is going to open or allow to open
drive-in movie theaters which of course
there aren't that many I don't think
there's any in New York City but
certainly a lot of New York state most
most of New York State is relatively
rural and I don't know the number of
drive-in theaters but it's an activity
and it is something that people can do
this is the type of thing that should be
done now because it adds almost no risk
but it builds capital because people
feel like something is going on now it
only works if people do the things they
need to do when they are doing these
different things Charlie Baker here in
Massachusetts yesterday announced that
they're going to announce some first
phase openings that could happen as soon
as next week I assume it will be very
minor low-risk stuff but again the
psychological Bennett
that will be very big blue states are
doing better at this than red states in
total red states have been either doing
the the stay-at-home order where people
are rebelling and it's imploding or
doing nothing and the virus is spreading
like wildfire that there actually is a
middle ground here it involves very low
risk activities harm reduction making
people aware that there are things they
could and even should be doing that are
going to be good for their mental health
and their physical health and get you
more buy-in and allow people to behave
safely for a longer period of time
hopefully we'll see more governors do
these types of things
privacy calm is one of our sponsors and
they're giving you $5.00 just for using
their free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman privacy's of service I've been
using for a while now I love it it saves
me a bunch of headaches it's completely
free and it's very quick to set up and
here's how it works
when you pay for something online or
over the phone instead of exposing your
real credit card number privacy lets you
generate virtual card numbers the
payments are withdrawn from your
checking account but your real card
number stays completely private and you
do it all with one click you can
autofill the card number in your web
browser on the phone you can create 12
virtual cards a month you can set
spending limits freeze them delete them
whenever you want I especially love it
for free trials where you need to give a
credit card number because I can destroy
the virtual card number as soon as I
give it to the company and I know I
won't be charged in the future if you're
ordering food over the phone why do I
need to give a restaurant my real card
number I don't have to companies don't
have to know who you are your real
credit card number is protected from the
data breaches that happen unfortunately
more often than we would like and it's
completely free they do have a paid
version with different tiers where you
can create more virtual credit card
numbers per month cash back rewards
extra security features but go ahead and
sign up for the free service it's a no
brainer companies can't charge you
unexpectedly you're protected from
identity theft that costs you nothing
and privacy is giving you five dollars
to spend
just for signing up when you go to
privacy comm slash Pakman